hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Blair which buddy
or bullet well come here bullet boat you
need to go find me a lighter fire ok it
must be in one of the other camps
because I'm willing to bet that there's
got to be a lighter somewhere I just
gotta locate it I don't exactly have
like an objective screen or anything so
I just gotta kind of guess unless there
was a lighter back there or less there's
a lighter in my pocket but I don't think
that there's a lighter anywhere here I'm
gonna look for it and I will be back
once they find it
ok good bang oh oh oh you're onto
something you're onto something you're
onto something what are you on do what
have you got what do you got good boy
I was a good boy who's a good boy who's
a good boy Oh what do you got what do
you got what do you got what do you got
what do you got
what are you where where what is it what
yeah what is it I don't see anything not
seeing anything I don't see nothing I
don't see anything here I see a like a
nail file what what what hope listen I I
love you but did nothing up you if you
found something bring it to me I I don't
see what you're talking about is this
because I died up against the fuse box
because I'm an idiot
is this because I did that it's probably
because I did that didn't it I must have
really broken the game when when that
happened I don't understand what you
want boy what is it tell me get it get
it must be something else I'm doing
wrong of course the tape tape the tape
the tape the tape is a red tape
I bet I don't even need doing now I'm
gonna watch through the camera for a
little bit let's see and zoom zoom watch
this watch this
I bet I bet I just bet okay I bet I knew
I knew it I knew it I knew it I knew it
yeah give me a pressure give me a fuel
whoa yeah give me fuel give me fire give
me that's what I desire whoa baby pull
don't pull so hard pull hard pull harder
pull harder pull hard pull hard
what do you mean without blowing the
gauge everything's fine cause it's all
done it's out of the way right is it out
of the way oh did I not get it all the
way over no I got it all the way out of
the way it's fine all right let's get
out of here let's go baby come on hop
off we gots to go all right let's do
this
here we go Oh some ominous music going
on hey let me actually I'm gonna bring
up the camera toggle night-vision on
this I bet there are things to see on
this camera whoa what happened whoa what
happened whoa yeah bet there are things
to be seen that you wouldn't oh I can oh
[ __ ] I didn't know I could do that
Oh weird oh I don't like that oh I don't
like that none at all you're right buddy
good grade yeah let's go baby let's go
oh oh well bullet oh he's still with me
buddy bullets
it's fine buddy we're fine don't ask me
how I know we're fine I didn't see what
happened
oh okay please I love you just a little
further all good all good I'll get it
okay soku right hey faster please
faster
limb okay all good
oh yeah this is this feels safer
[Music]
okay well we almost died okay here got
cell signals all right let's give a good
old call hey Jess yes I'm busy that's a
little peculiar don't know why okay cool
good thanks alright it's going
swimmingly this is going delectably is
going delightfully nice cheap things
popping things and I don't even know if
they're real or not I I don't know which
is worse it's Damon's to explain thanks
for everything
uh-huh okay all right little weird man
our dynamic is something special I
suppose may I ask who is a good boy
who's a handsome good boy
is it you I can't see you but I'm
assuming that there's a good boy right
in front of me I'm just gonna keep this
in night vision mode and kind of have it
in the corner in case I see something I
don't like too much hey bullet stay stay
close buddy stay stay close hey you see
anything Search Search buddy yeah I love
a good drop-off whee
I'm wondering if there are things that
this cameras gonna show because that's
what the notes from probably the crazy
guy was saying
woman okay well Oh weird
all right cool whatever whatever you say
hey no biggie no biggie no bigs no
biggie no biggie
this is it no biggie the place we were
looking for is it okay whatever you say
buddy good great good great great great
okay great all right what you got boy
what you got boy hey I got cell service
you don't know what the good that's
gonna do for me hey sorry to bother you
again oh yeah I'm just learning the
basics of wood cutting why mrs. luge
keep that up and I'll be blushing like a
schoolgirl no luck so far but I think
I'm getting close I will call you later
miss Lynch so are we married or or what
cuz it seemed like seems like our
relationship weren't doing so hot not
abandoned not a bin if someone lives
here someone lives here someone lives
here
right you know don't blame me when I
don't really believe you that someone
lives here I now I don't like it because
I think I'm actually gonna see something
and I'm not gonna like it
okay we got a tape great let's watch it
yeah we'll get you what's this a really
low speed chase I'll get you okay low
speed fight
yes yes yeah yeah yeah I mean I know
what but even so it's it's so weird oh I
don't like that I don't like that bull
it's really weird huh weird like I guess
I get your bullet it's okay it's okay
look hey it's it's okay just weird magic
hey your Pappy's got some nice magical
camera stuff going on Oh boom
yes it's it's just magic bud but it's
just magic come on kid with the program
alright come on bud stay close all right
so this was open for it oh oh oh what am
I seeing am i seeing a head is that head
or is that a foot that's a foot wait
there's a book us a boot down a hand
Oscar Burton a hand so this thing open
for just a little bit got you
hey not safe when I've got my magic
camera it's like the Magic School Bus
but even more magical
numbers I like numbers three three to
four good great good great good hello
I saw it not a witch or a monster but a
man a man carrying a pelt of a skinned
human he saw me and now he's coming then
Carver I had enough time to type up this
note however I'm a man of a lot of time
and plenty of Bluebird Barbara wasn't
Bluebird the name of the developer of
this game interesting oh oh okay oh oh
oh oh okay someone's a little obsessed
which is yeah right don't exist okay so
I got to find a way to get upstairs or
something that's where that's where all
the death happened that's where I want
to go hey come here
come here boy hey how about you uh how
about you go find something seek cool
find something all from there huh okay
all right well I guess I'm on my own
then all right here oh three three to
four huh I could have read for my way
through but whatever whatever I guess I
don't even need to exercise my big brain
okay yeah sure show me the goods all
right and dead body am I supposed to
just walk up to that and where's that
dead body oh yeah yeah come on we all
got problems buddy Oh
oh hi blood still fresh some of those
are defense wounds multiple cuts badly
mutilated
oh let me just let me just coop shank Oh
oh wait hey what hey hey right oh Jesus
Christ
what the [ __ ] just happened
yeah I was wondering about that I
thought that there was some else
happening chance someone right yeah yeah
his face yeah he's ugly too unfortunate
for this guy got murdered and hideously
ugly could leave the murder yeah good
name for
[Music]
wait what words where'd they go what
what happened is shooting him okay
I'm a little confused as to how that
went down also what was he going for the
window what Oh what
okay I'll kill you it give me I'll kill
you
what I'll kill you I'll kill you I'll
kill you I'll kill you up do you get
over here I'll kill you I'll kill you
I'll kill you I'll kill you
I'll kill you I will kill you I will
kill you you killed Lani
where's Peter what have you done to him
it's not stop messing with me or or what
yeah for right now yeah scared
[Music]
yeah I'll punch I'll do more than punch
a man up I'll beat the crap out of you
I'll Drive you in the next year or you
think mr. brambles around my neck is
really a problem here
try me buddies rhyming hey that's cool
you know what my will is for you to go
away and for there's a saw with your
name on it actually it's really funny
you're surrounded by wood this whole
place is purpose is actually to cut wood
in half so why don't you just jump into
the saw head first no actually the legs
first I'd appreciate that a bit more
anyway also don't know why my computer
is running like a turd they're number
one
where's bullet and number two I hate you
how are you doing here private it was me
sir what was Elisha five I was the point
man sir what are you trying to say
soldier I let those men into the ambush
sir
[Music]
nine injured six dead six grieving
widows not orphaned children
soldier
he should have been court-martialed whoa
trippy I couldn't stay
after that it wasn't your fault Ellis
[Music]
oh yeah that's right this guy I gotta
beat him up
hey you've messed with it see this knife
I remember holding it against my wrist
okay I seen a deeper and deeper wanting
to end it all to silence the voices weak
pathetic ah say that to my space I
should have listened from the start
that's what set me free
uh-huh you'll understand soon enough
alright yeah okay this whole like I
don't know what that's all about
not I represent sure God wait a minute
but dreadmill here and just left well
lit border miss you to a handsome boy
what oh wait I've got it what do you
want I know what's going on I know
what's going on
I know I know what's going on I know I
know I've got this all figured eyes I've
got this all figured out
I've got it all figured out the tapes
make sense
shut up Carter I'm about to reveal a
relevant revelation okay here's what I
think is going on
Carter is Ellis they're the same person
because Ellis is going crazy why
I think justice already dead the eyes
are your Ellis's does the rest of doody
doody maybe not I don't know I think
it's gonna be a really grim dark ending
go be a boy but I'll give you a treat
because I can at least for right now
[Music]
that's what you get is you good boy good
boy you go good boy you feel good you
did you good boy I think Jesse's already
dead
that's why here's the smoking gun I
don't have the camera for right now but
why would the police officer be walking
around with the guy who did the thing
why would bullet
trust Carter and just be like hey
everything's good no something don't add
up it's all rotten
but how we've taken years for it to get
this bad doesn't make sense
patient is in for monthly appointment in
relation to his anxiety neurosis seems
kept in check again no discussion of the
woods or his friend dissociative amnesia
worsening the woods his friend I admit
this patient is beginning to concern me
everyone seems to have moved on but the
fact that he does not talk about the
woods at all is almost eerie he has
become interested in hiking hunting was
offered a scholarship out of state but
does not want to leave town something is
keeping him here what's going on what do
you got buddy what do you got we looking
at why see uh camera ah I see
[ __ ] bastard right okay oh I've got
supervision now I can see everything Oh
what the hell Oh what's going on on
earth these are all the developers I bet
that's all the developers that were like
well everyone stand up against the wall
and be creepy I bet that's all just the
developers weird a bud very weird I
don't even have options anymore that's
why the camera can change things because
it's all in my memory and I just need to
remember where it is it's all in my mind
I've got this figured out oh I know
what's going on here
I know this is all just me working
through some things maybe Jess isn't
dead but I would not be surprised if
just dead I would not be surprised right
unless I'm wrong I might be wrong what
do you guys think I might I might be way
off base here but I'm thinking Ben Ellis
has dumped something horrible right why
whatever he'll be walking around with
this guy in the woods it doesn't make
any sense and then how does the witch
play into this wait maybe I'm wrong
maybe I'm wrong because how would the
witch play into all this you know what I
mean
that's what I don't get maybe I'm
off-base hey wait a minute hey come on
now you can't you can't do that to me
no not that again hey buddy uh can you
can you uh go seek something out go try
to find some go find something hey go
find something ain't got nothin nothin
really
come on I don't remember where the white
tree was in relation to here so I'm just
gonna wander aimlessly for a while oh
you can't be do that to me that doesn't
make the most sense okay what if I
follow this track he betrayal I didn't
see this coming this way before I think
I have to follow the trail okay ah I
think I have to follow the trail
interesante inter oh oh oh with a little
something that is why that's bad yeah
what's up hey how you doing buddy
uh-huh what what are you talking on
straight I I wonder
talk about the dog like - a good dog
okay here you Strickler stick close to
me and you're a good boy good boy good
boy you gonna let me give you a little
little that's a good boy yes good boy
okay keep your eyes on the camera huh
okay oh oh oh oh oh I don't like this oh
I don't like this at Pole jumpy downy
how far down oh oh
stay close bullets stay close
stick together bullet I don't want to
lose you in this fog yeah I can't see
you on my gambarro this guy go for the
tree yes I don't need your help is that
it is that the sign I think that might
be the sign is this the sign sign sign
sign well that's not
oh maybe I shouldn't listen to this guy
and maybe this guy's joshing me
something serious hey maybe this guy's
giving me the reach-around and not the
good kind maybe this guy's giving me the
ring around the day was okay
oh oh well I mean I would just gonna
circumnavigate them just a wittle little
bit what's this thing oh hi Oh take that
yeah whatever
no I'm not afraid ain't afraid I'm brave
I'm big and brave I'm big brave what
give me a point oh yeah oh wait come
here boy boy where's Bullock come here
boy I'm not leaving
where's commute hey hey hey
I hate that no no no they won't you
don't know that
where is holy no I'm not I got a fine
bullet hey there you are good boy good
boy no boy you seem to be stuck Hey oh
you're stuck aren't you heal anybody
well you you are you all right can you
please search holy Oh stay close but
look can you please I well you made me
do this because it's the only way that I
could think to reset this thing yeah I
don't know what happened but hopefully
bullet is good heal okay stay close
bullet
stay close this time I can't keep dying
for you like that okay all right there's
nothing don't get stuck on that okay
good good good good
don't get stuck stay close boys stay
close buddy stay close okay where's that
tank Oh I hear them
this way buddy no no no no no don't
don't be growling don't be growling and
nothing don't worry okay all right we
should be smooth sailin now I don't know
if we're getting any closer to this
thing though it sure doesn't feel like
it still there buddy this point
[Applause]
okay who's they by the way I would like
to know who they is cuz they seems to be
a bit of an enigma at this point
oh hey they okay I see big nothing
I see the tree it's almost here real
close now the tree hooray the tree
okay good okay now that I'm here I'm
gonna love the Train well that's a weird
name for a save okay but we made it
okay so well that sucked but suck but
hey we made it and I feel good about
myself maybe so thank you everybody so
much for watching I'll pick this up real
soon don't you worry eat it thanks again
everybody and let me know what you
thought down the comments below and as
always see you in the next video bye
[Music]